Some people will tell you that a great relationship is based on the attraction of opposites.
Others say you have to have taste, interest and personality types in common or your marriage will fail.
So which one is true?
Well, neither guarantees success.
What does matter is that you and your partner share identical core values.
Yes, I said identical.
Not similar, identical.
The closer you match your partner's values, the better your chances of making it in your marriage.
Values are the principles that guide our actions, particularly in relation to others.
They express how we think people should behave.
When we act out of value, we're doing our part to make the world...
...the way we think it should be, not just the way it is.
Values inspire us to attempt that very lofty goal.
Another thing about values, they're not situation specific.
No matter what the circumstance is, values hold.
Goals can change, desires can adjust.
But our sense of what is right on a gut level cannot be altered.
So discover your values and your partner's values and start finding common ground.